[Music]
you know one of my favorite pieces of
extra content that we post on our
youtube channel are my reddit
relationship advice videos and this is
when i comb through the relationship
forums on reddit to impart my wisdom to
the confused and helpless souls who are
so desperate that they're actually
stooping to soliciting advice from the
reddit community now my advice may not
be great from an objective standpoint
but it's better than anything that you
know they'll get from reddit so
today in that spirit i'll be trying to
help a young woman whose relationship
quandary has posted to reddit went viral
this week um i'll be helping her and
i'll also be canceling her because
that's what we do in this segment
nothing personal
i mean usually it is pretty personal but
never mind that a woman named kate
whitaker on twitter
seems to be one of the first to have
taken this post and amplified it causing
it to go viral she tweeted the
screenshot along with a caption
revealing her bias she says what on
earth is going on with men
ironically though the man in question is
not on earth he is under the earth where
all men wish to be
the reddit post is titled how can i get
my boyfriend to stop digging his tunnel
now we see the problem already from the
way she framed the situation she says
how can i get him to stop
rather than
should i get him to stop which is the
real question you should be asking she's
assuming from the outset that she should
stop her boyfriend from digging his
tunnel to her it's self-evident that men
should not dig tunnels but to men
it's self-evident that we should and we
must
i'm getting ahead of myself a little bit
here's um her version of the story let's
read it
she says so i know this is a weird
question but my boyfriend likes to spend
a lot of his free time digging a tunnel
on some property that he inherited i
haven't seen the full extent of it but
last i saw it was remarkably deep under
the surface he spent roughly a year on
it and it's evident
the front of the thing is deep wide well
put together at the front which is the
only part i've seen he's got cement
beams cement beams electric lights even
chairs and a small table
i haven't gotten into it i haven't gone
into it but it looked like the quality
severely dropped as the tunnel went
further
mostly becoming open dirt with some wood
beams holding it up
now pausing here for a moment
it is baffling to me that her boyfriend
has been digging this awesome tunnel and
she hasn't even gone into it
this is like if he had spent a year
painting a masterpiece or chiseling a
beautiful sculpture out of rock and you
didn't even bother to look at it what if
you were in the sistine chapel
michelangelo in the year 1512 and he
told you that he just finished painting
the ceiling
and he's like i just finished painting
that whole ceiling it took me forever
and you're just like oh cool and you
didn't even bother to look up and check
it out this is shocking to me
especially when the thing in question is
a badass tunnel
she continues
my biggest concern is his safety i'm
really worried that he's going to dig
too deep and it'll collapse on him or
something i've tried voicing this
concern to him but he just laughs it off
and assures me that he'll be fine aside
from safety concerns there's also the
fact that he doesn't really have a
social life because of this thing
i'm pretty much the only person he still
talks to outside of his job and he
doesn't go out and do anything anymore
it used to be that he'd occasionally
head out and do some digging on the
weekends but now he spends almost all of
his free time out there he still comes
home but he barely spends any time with
me and i know that he isn't going to be
he isn't doing anything but digging that
damn hole in the ground this can't be
good for his mental health but i don't
know how to convince him to stop he's
always really happy when he comes back
from digging which is why i haven't
seriously tried to stop him before
but i was talking to a friend about him
and she told me he might be going crazy
obviously i don't think he's insane but
i hadn't considered the mental health
aspect of this and i just don't know
what to do
okay let's clear a few things
up now yes sure there are some valid
safety concerns here if the tunnel isn't
properly built and supported or
ventilated you could you know
die but let's just put the risk of death
aside for a second that's a minor detail
frankly and also i see no reason for us
to assume given the information provided
that this man is digging his tunnel in
an unsafe way that would be i believe an
erroneous assumption so
let's table the whole dying situation
for a moment
and uh look at the bigger picture
first of all
speaking to the woman who wrote this
your problem fundamentally is that you
think you have to understand everything
about the man you're dating but you
can't and you won't
woman will never fully comprehend man
just as man will never fully comprehend
woman we are made for each other and yet
we are mysteries to each other that's
the essence of romance
the difference though is that man knows
he cannot understand woman and he's okay
with that
woman in fact becomes very frustrated by
just how okay with it he is
so you know she'll say something cryptic
and out of context to him and he'll have
no idea what she's talking about but
he'll just go oh okay
uh okay
and then get back to what he's doing and
she'll stand there stunned and say well
aren't you gonna ask me what i'm talking
about
and he'll say okay yeah what were you
talking about and he'll just hope it
isn't a long story but it always is
on the flip side man can say nothing at
all he can simply walk into the room
with a slightly abnormal facial
expression and woman will start
interrogating and waterboarding him to
extract every last piece of information
she can about this facial expression
what are you thinking she'll ask
and she won't accept it when he says
nothing even if that really is the
answer
she must understand everything about him
but she won't
and she can't accept that
and even though she won't
i will now endeavor to lay out a few
facts about men that may help women
especially this woman
the first is this
every man dreams of two things often
related
having a secret door in his house that
leads to a secret room
and building a great tunnel
this tunnel might connect one secret
room to another or it might simply go
all the way down to the center of the
earth where we hope we'll
expect to find goblins and dinosaurs and
elvis hiding out or whatever
um there's something cathartic about
digging
we are called into the earth into the
caverns we hear the siren song just as
our forefathers did assuming our
forefathers were meerkats or dwarves
from middle earth or something
you can't understand this we don't
understand this and yet this is just how
it is
the other thing about men
is that we're prone to becoming randomly
obsessed with very weird and specific
things out of nowhere
again we cannot explain this
we shouldn't have to explain it
for example
i recently decided that i want to get a
giant aquarium with lots of rare and
tropical fish in my house
and i keep telling my wife about it and
she keeps wanting to understand why i'm
obsessed with being a fish owner all of
a sudden and i keep telling her that
actually it's called fish keeping
according to all the videos i've watched
about it and she says wait you're
watching videos about people who own
fish
and i say they're fish keepers and yes
and around around we go
a man becomes bizarrely fixated on some
arbitrary thing
a woman looks on confused
and it's the great dance of life
then we get to the biggest problem that
i noticed in this story
needless to say i noticed no problems
with a man who simply wants nothing but
to dig
all of the problems as usual are with
the woman
especially when she acknowledges that
the man is happy when he digs he's
fulfilled he's doing what he wants to do
what he's called to do and yet she
talked to her friend and decided that
though he's happy and seemingly mentally
well adjusted he must be crazy
women listen
i know i'm not going to stop you from
talking to your friends
but just realize that if you who spend
every day with your man still struggle
to understand all of his ways
then what chance does your friend have
what insight can she really offer about
him what does she know
is she even in a healthy relationship
herself
has she even seen the tunnel
or is she making judgments about the
tunnel without all the facts
a tale is all this time
the meddling friend
this is the scourge of men everywhere
so
just stop that ladies let the man be let
him be a man let him dig
let him get his eighteen thousand dollar
aquarium
yes it's eighteen thousand dollars
but it's worth the investment
[Music]
and it helps with equity in your home or
something maybe
anyway let him live damn it that's all
i'm saying otherwise
you're cancelled if you enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up and
share it with all your friends